hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
we're here and by we i usually mean just
me but this time i mean us
me and my wife kristen she's here dude
and we brought her here because of first
of all actually let me just
since the thumbnail is going to be
popping and we're going to get a lot of
views and it's going to be absolutely
we're going to do stupid numbers uh let
me go to my tour first before we even
get into it before we get into it let's
get some this is what they do in the
radios they say let's pay some bills so
we're going to go to the
tour
section of my podcast
grand prairie coming for you
chrissalia.com i'll be there that's the
dallas play
uh i'm doing it there wichita kansas
atlanta georgia washington dc these are
all the places that i'm going to be
going and touring and [ __ ] chris
leah.com stockton california oakland
california bring your heaters
uh peoria illinois and every time i
think of peoria i think of that [ __ ]
song and peoria
and new york it's a little shop of
horrors did it didn't get the part i
wanted in high school all good rockford
illinois raleigh north carolina which is
where she's from uh chrisley.com october
22nd to be in savannah georgia then
denver colorado november 5th 2022
cheyenne wyoming boston massachusetts
we're doing two shows at the wang you
boyfill seats in the [ __ ] upper east
side and uh albany new york lakefront
florida and jacksonville florida
chrisley.com for tickets and that's
where we're going and also uh let's play
some let's play some bills
this just came out this just came out
today so go get your periwinkle shits i
got the shorts on two which look really
good i'm not gonna stand up because it's
too cumbersome back here oh wait we got
the shorts here dude check that out
these are for you babe
thank you life rips you're welcome so
grateful um
and then we got the hoodie
we got it going right here with the
hoodie that's for you babe thank you so
grateful robot
thank you um so yeah so chrisley.com and
go to chrisley.com to get that
periwinkle [ __ ] and i don't know if you
know this babe because i'm high on
fashion and you're probably high on
fashion too but dude the periwinkle
shits that's the color that's popping
this summer oh is it and i can't help
that but what i do is i've been with the
times
right i've been with the times and
that's what i did here they said
periwinkle's pop and [ __ ] and i go let
me take a look at the pedro winkle and
they say okay and they take a look at
the periwinkle and they say how does
life rips what and then i cut myself off
and they say how does the puffy print
look and they go
we didn't even think about that so we
put the puffy print on the left rip [ __ ]
and it's periwinkle and whoopsie daisy
we stuck with the times but we're still
keeping it raw and real and uncut
speaking of raw my nose hurts like [ __ ]
yeah
yes dude but this is the reason why i
brought her on the podcast okay
i did surgery i don't mean i did surgery
like i was the guy who did it with the
steady hand like the doctor i went to
sergio as you could tell because of my
nose okay now i said i got a nose job
that's not entirely true i mean i did
get a job on my nose sure and it was a
deviated septum because i couldn't
breathe for a long time
yeah and i didn't know that okay
um first of all give it up for my
beautiful wife kristen
now i didn't know i could breathe not
breathe that well you were hiding it
from me because she didn't want me to
feel insecure about my snorings yeah
well it has to be my fault no it's no
it's it's it's not your fault this is me
showing you what a [ __ ] large heart
you have oh okay like when they say the
grinch
uh
hard uh it's two sizes it grew two sizes
too big
or whatever how many sizes too small is
it who knows you know because you've
seen the [ __ ] thing so many times
sure how many times is it a lot okay so
don't know a specific number though
but
but so that's your heart normally right
that's your heart normally is at the end
with the grinch okay and yours is the
little bean now i was going to say that
you took my slam boyfriend it's going to
be a self-slam you took that and that's
unfair because it's my show we'll be
faster all right so so we're gonna have
her on because i don't remember this i
got i had a deviated septum you were
being very sweet about it right about
not uh being shitty about my snoring
yeah and i talked to the nose doctor
yeah the ear nose and throat the nt and
he was like you probably snore a lot
right and i was like you know what it's
funny she says i don't and then i look
over to you and she's like actually uh
yeah you know what i kind of you do
snore a lot because
i just don't say it because i don't want
you to feel bad yeah by the way
if you don't get good sleep you die
early so basically you were contributing
to my early death yes nice well i am
agreed on it with that okay i'm a heavy
sleeper to begin with
but it's only when you would do these um
it it seemed like you were dying you
would go like
in the middle of the night and that you
know what i was dreaming that was my
love for you it was a good thing
so much did you hear me sometimes i
would say that when i wake up so much
though no i yeah i only heard the um
scary breath cool
and then it would you would fall back
asleep and then you would snore pretty
heavily okay well
you should have been on upfront with
that in the beginning maybe i would have
had some better sleep
we learned to be upfront right okay do
you want me to tell you from now on all
the things that irritate me no no no
okay no no no this is an hour-long show
so uh so
so she's here because i got the surgery
and i and she was telling me [ __ ] that
went down that i did not remember
because i was under no i had gotten
general anesthesia before for my leg
right because
um on my knee i got i got um
uh what do you call it i had a bucket
handle tear um what do you call it
meniscus meniscus yeah
and uh
and i had the meniscus
and uh the doctor tells me to put this
on i'm not gonna have this on i don't
need it um
we do our own i prescribe my own [ __ ] um
yeah so um
so yeah uh
i mean last thing i want to do is get
blood on this periwinkle [ __ ] but right
wait what was i saying so i got the so
anesthesia well this is good to have you
here yeah you remind me of [ __ ] okay so
anna sees it so i got anesthesia and i
got on my leg woke up and i was like
smooth sailing i don't know what was up
with the anesthesia i don't even know if
they really did it to me but like i woke
up and i was like i didn't feel weird at
all this time
some very weird [ __ ] went down i had no
idea about that it was gonna be going
down and i don't remember it and she
does and that's why i brought her on the
podcast because she's going to tell you
what the [ __ ] i did now i don't believe
a lot of this [ __ ] wow because you know
i'm a real man dude i'm i'm a [ __ ] i'm
tough dude
okay
well before you were even
on our way to the hospital you were
saying
i will absolutely remember everything
i'm going to wake up and remember every
single thing you wait and see and i said
okay okay well talk to you later babe
isn't that true i don't even remember
that baby i don't even remember saying
that i
i'm not saying i didn't say that i'm
saying maybe the anesthesia was already
in effect in my mind i don't even
remember what road we were on okay well
don't say that people will know where we
live okay
um
so
so all right well first of all let's
just back up
even to
let's we're going to tell the story but
that cup is the most annoying cup i've
ever seen in the world now that mug
right there no i know i know i get it
dude i can't even make fun of it i think
because it's a lovely thing so explain
the [ __ ] cup first of all it's taking
up too much screen
the amount of like we're going to put
graphics in this [ __ ] we're going to put
them over your face because this it
leaves no room for the [ __ ]
put them over your face
we you gotta don't bite in the hand
right okay so what's the [ __ ] so just
explain the [ __ ] cup it's so tall and
there's no explaining it's a it's a
coffee mug that i got at the tower of
london what was there to say so cute all
right but it's so tall dude you don't
need it that big it's like you might as
well be saying huzzah every time you
drink out of it i like drinking my
coffee immediately so i put a lot of
milk in it to cool it down and so i need
the extra little bit
so big dude you're one to talk look at
yours it's off off to the side though
i'm good with it like off to the side
also you could see through mine you know
what i mean
so we could switch the cup we bought
another mug
in case but we don't need to do that so
all right so listen dude
so
i get to the [ __ ] i get so i'm gonna
get this thing i don't wanna i don't
like i don't do drugs right right i
don't do drugs i've taken a few trips to
any island and you know i get nice with
the vive ants when i'm on a boat okay
yeah and that's
four said yeah i know she's like come on
you don't need to be a dick to my
friends take some vivants and i'm like
i'm a five advanced boy if we're going
to be doing something like go to sea
right if i got to be really i'm going to
go to an amusement park i'll snort
vivants right how many times did i ask
you to drink on her oh
in london ten times i counted she asked
dude she's a pusher dude i want him to
be not so square like i think that
broadening his
his mind opening himself up to
experiences that he has admittedly never
done on purpose i think it would be
really really good for you honey wow
dude you seem like such a nice person
dude
and that's so annoying because you're a
pusher dude
yeah you're a drug pusher yeah dude i
don't
i get nice with it on viva it's only
because of you
you asked me to do violence i was like
all right i'll do it
i had a [ __ ] blast i think you might
have given me ecstasy but what came out
of it you had a great time great time
great story i did have a great story all
of my friends were like who is this
charismatic charming man that we've
never met i'm good with your friends man
he's i mean that seems like abc check
check check
i know but it's just like
what's next cocaine no dude i can't wait
with my nose
it's true all right dude if you see me
in a few weeks and my teeth are looking
real ragged you know she pushed meth on
me so listen um
so i'm not good with the drugs i didn't
want to do it i never really i never do
it and i i had to do the uh uh
anesthesia they can't any time they go
local i'm like do just do it local like
my people are like oh yeah i got my my
uh wisdom teeth out and i said oh yeah
did you get put under it they go of
course did you i go [ __ ] no dude if the
shit's lo i would have done it with my i
almost did it with my neighbor you're
saying local is in local anesthesia yeah
okay
no in my house i mean yeah so so the
doctor was like in your knee i'm just
going to do it local i'll put you on a
little bit of a twilight in an
anesthesia and i was like good i'm up he
put me out completely because he thought
i was going to be he's like you seem too
nervous
hmm
something to think about prequel that
was the [ __ ] jar jar binks episode of
what has come in the star wars franchise
okay because what we do now is
we go to the place now i don't want to
do it i don't want to get my [ __ ] my
nose done right
but i have a deviated septum and i'm
going to die early if i don't do this
okay it's dire
even though she's lying to me she's
saying i don't
i don't snore right i'm a liar so
so
so i get to the place
and what what happens why don't you go
ahead
okay
what point do you want me to start at
well okay we get to the place
is that where you want me to start i get
to the i got to put the stuff on yeah
the
what do they call it very cute all right
and you said what i look what
undercover section alert no okay but
don't emasculate me cutie alert all
right dude we don't we do
all right so what what do i look like
though you said strangely sexy is how i
look in it yeah strangely sexy describe
it please for the audience genie tiny
legs huge broad shoulders though very
sexy and a hairnet okay but why
strangely sexy because i don't
mysterious
handsome no but you said no this is what
i remember you see you're using the
anesthesia it wasn't kicked in yet i
didn't use it what you said was because
you look so big in it and it looks like
unnatural that you look strangely sexy
in it yes i did say that okay and i
stand by it
okay so i had to hand it in too like i
was a lunch lady yeah all right so i
looked like a trans lunch lady so
so i was in the thing right and um
i was very big and beefy right and she
puts the the doctor the anesthesiologist
so the anesthesiologist is the doctor's
wife very sweet she comes in so sweet
and
she puts the iv in your hand yeah
and
from
the two days prior you had been quite
nervous i said very nervous last night
and you stopped me and you said i was
nervous wait wait wait like i was
retelling this to our friends no mike
and haley last night and i said you were
very nervous and the day's leading up
and you said no
just nervous i was okay it wasn't very
okay was it kicking i'm clarifying okay
telling stories around you is the
hardest thing ever
you're such a stickler for keeping you
accountable thank you okay
okay i wasn't shaking sure i was he
wasn't shaking put a pin in it okay he
wasn't shaking i'm a man and you
described that that i look like a
[ __ ] trade lunch lady when i had the
[ __ ] hair net on okay okay so she
puts the iv in yes and he
keeps asking her questions about the
procedure to a point where i knew that
he was getting nervous he was like is it
okay
i i can't remember but he's getting
persecuted for it but okay that's fine
but he wants it for johnny wants info
but they're gonna they're gonna put him
on the cross but okay go ahead
that's fine
why don't i do this while you tell the
story the only reason i'm even bringing
it up was because i could tell he was
getting nervous by the way that he was
talking to her now we dropped the
extremely didn't we because we realized
the truth go ahead
you're right because what happened next
wasn't the most extreme thing i've ever
[ __ ] seen
hurts when i left all good worth it just
the whole thing was like such a
crystally a surgery experience you know
so anyways
she says why don't i give you a little
something to ease your nerves because i
can tell that you're nervous okay and
you said nah
yeah i did and that's when i said uh-oh
okay but what i did in my mind was
because you wanna oh in your mind what i
did is i'm gonna get [ __ ] anyway i might
as well just ride this out and
experience it while i can sure because
the doctor doesn't know best no no she
does know best but you know what she
doesn't know inside my mind right right
okay now i don't want
her telling me what she thinks i should
be doing when i already know what's
happening inside my mind now so deeper
yes of course
deeper
okay you don't even really know what's
going on inside your mind who does but i
have a little bit of a gist of what's
going on better than she does so i say
nah [ __ ] it i'll just you know she says
okay cool right so then what happens the
doctor comes in the surgeon who's
married to the anesthesiologist right he
comes in here's mr jokes a lot the guy
jokes all the time we should also
preface it with he's like the best is
the best country he's the best so if i
if i were in your shoes i would have
been like oh he's got this whatever he's
doing to me obviously is the right thing
and i'm fine and you were not really in
that head space you were more in like a
defensive
who's [ __ ] with me right now i'm a
ceo technically right okay so some of of
my business so someone's gonna come in
and they're gonna tell me how [ __ ] goes
i get that i'm in your business but also
i'm a ceo too
okay yeah so it's more of a meeting of
the minds than it is you tell me what to
do now you're no offense not a ceo so
when you go in what do i do ceo with me
it's like when trump met the [ __ ] guy
from north korea oh maybe we shouldn't
be doing this but let's work on some
[ __ ] together right
jesus christ so i get there and the guy
is like
the guy is like uh the doctor no
disrespect the doctor is like hey what's
up what are we doing so uh let's do it
let's lean back already joking he jokes
so much and it's great he tries to put
people at ease but for me i already joke
a lot and i want the real facts right
because i am
nervous now let's put a pin in it not
extremely not very but nervous
right anxious paranoid
but he's so he before we even go in
we're in the lazy boy chair we're not
even in the gurney yet right sure
um and i know you have to get to your
just just a virtual class but i wanted
her to be here for this
story okay
so because we're gonna do the regular
episode after this but i just you know i
wanted to
so because she remembers [ __ ] i don't
you're kind of the one that's stringing
this along yeah i understand it's a slam
but it's fine dude let's remember who
show it is
all good
okay so
it's kind of our show now right no okay
dude
no okay what's your yours is mine
no dude we didn't that's what we value
we did not actually say that in the vows
we didn't technically say those words
that's true so uh would you what's yours
is mine even the podcast
so um
so [ __ ]
so we're at the uh the thing so the guy
says um okay so i'm gonna want you to
lean back he takes this very long steel
i mean how long is it but how why does
this get the very it was long
wow dude okay like if if the other thing
is not gonna get the very considering
what happened afterwards i think that
this should not get the very also i i
really appreciate how you're how you're
breaking this down thank you but you're
wrong
and i will tell you why i really i
really do appreciate you and that's why
i love you right but it's wrong
it's wrong and i'll tell you why because
you have to break it down for what it is
right is it very long
if you're
uh you know going to put it next to a
cadillac no the cadillac's longer okay
especially if it's from 1978 right nine
seventy eight
but those are long as [ __ ] one time my
buddy dave meeting was trying to walk
and turn over he was he's walking along
a cadillac and it was parked and he was
trying to take a left and it was like
taking so long he was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] god damn it and he hit his knee
even though he was watching that's how
long it was he took a left and he's like
god the [ __ ] day was so long i hit my
knee and i was watching bro we left so
hard we were outside of taco bell and um
a side note
on the side note i already decided i
know but side side note i always wonder
how we get these little um like carpet
fuzzies yeah
right under you because i'm like he's
sitting in a chair how are these
well yeah you like really are in it yeah
dude you're moving your feet it's like a
like an exercise yeah i buck this is
like a peloton knock if you buck
okay yeah so do you remember that song
no give you buzz she does
so white
knock if you buck knock if you back
everybody down knock if few bucks so um
[Music]
ship station i want to talk to you about
this this company ship station when you
guys run a business time seems more
precious every misplaced moment feels
like a missed opportunity a lost chance
to make your business better or even
just to step away and recharge which is
important too take it from me
shipstation gives e-commerce sellers
like you more time to do what they
really really love unless what you
really love is managing every single
little detail of order fulfillment yeah
not me you know uh shipstation automates
time intensive shipping processes so you
can get back to focusing on bigger
things like developing new products
honing your marketing strategy or
interacting with customers uh
look shipstation is already trusted by
over 100 000 sellers uh and to that kind
of stuff i'm like no duh
because of how great it is okay
uh my favorite thing about ship station
uh is there are less tasks for my team
which means that happy fans are getting
their merch fast and faster than they
would be it's just great it's a
well-done machine it's a well-oiled
machine thank you thanks to ship station
all those manual shipping tasks eating
up your time ship station is really good
at those so let ship station handle all
your shipping and handling and get back
to what you're good at growing your
business you get deeply discounted
shopping rates normally reserved for
fortune 500 companies so uh that's you
you're basically a fortune 500 company
uh it's time to let go of all those
shipping tasks shipstation can do it
better and faster sign up using promo
code congrats
for a free
60-day trial today at shipstation.com
and start saving time with every
shipment what do you have to lose that's
two whole months of shipping made quick
and painless and it's free to try
just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in congrats
ship station make ship happen
[Music]
anyway so he is like uh so he takes a
very long thing for what it is dude he
takes an instrument that's going to be
used obviously on my body right
that's what it obviously he's getting
right
the the thing the thing that i said was
very long
sure yes
how long was it do it with your fingers
baby i would like to see
memory is so fickle oh but i remember
do you though yes i do because before
what say with me anesthesia
you didn't say women but you know what i
was gonna say or it was before what your
panic attack listen which means that you
were already fading mentally no i wasn't
okay do how long you think it was
with your with your hands i mean there's
no harm in that it's like
is this a trick no it's not a trick at
all so show that show the show the crowd
how long you think it is okay now where
am i gonna take it it's like i'm showing
how long your deck is no it wouldn't be
you have to move your hand a little bit
closer to me if you're going to do that
now i'll tell you this
the other hand
[Laughter]
so listen so listen so listen
do do how long you think it's because
this is an experiment oh who's sho hold
on let me who show is it let me google i
gotta google this dude can we do the
experiment please let me do the
experiment how long do you think the
thing was okay now
your honor what you're also your honor
by the way okay these are a lot of rules
what surgery what was i getting was that
was the septoplasty okay and where is
that located
in your nose and where and where is that
located on the body in your butt
ma'am this is not how it's gonna
ma'am let's do this again and do it for
real okay
where where is where is the uh the
guy where's he getting what do you call
him the guy on the stand
accused
defendant defender where's the defendant
um
where is the defendant uh getting us
getting surgery in his
nose and where is that nose
on his face okay and the face would
reside in the head right am i right so
so uh how large is the defendant's uh
face
including the nose quite big
uh ma your honor mark dinosaur slam
i think it's objection okay yeah but not
if it goes [ __ ] crazy dude okay so
listen dude let's do it can we not do
can we do it just like we were in an
actual courtroom please
it's your turn
so where was the surgery
in a hospital ma'am and in that hospital
where was the surgery gonna get
on his what on his nose and where does
the nose reside on his face and the face
resides in the head now how long is a
pha how long is a head
how long is a head front to back either
way ma'am top or bottom front i
would honestly have no idea how to
calculate that but i would say like
seven or so inches six or seven inches
okay now listen uh we're talking about
the client's uh face not as dick mark
that down please uh so uh
uh
my hands are hurting ma'am please just
further i know this is getting shorter
what's happening there erosion now
listen what we need to do is uh
mark this down uh is this larger than a
head
i want one answer ma'am that would be
fine one answer
is that larger than a head equal
ma'am is that larger than a head
yes
thank you your honor no further
questions okay now that we got to the
bottom of that right
so it's long so what so would you say
it's long for what it is
so if it's longer than what it is going
to be inside of would you say it's
longer than
it's long for what it is
what do i have to say for this to be
over yes yes your honor mark that down
as it is
uh the exhibit is longer than what it
needs to be and it is
[Laughter]
so he so he pulls it out
so he pulls it out and i see it and i go
whoa because it's too long to be doing
anything in my where my surgery is going
and he what puts it in my nostril
all the way in it's so long i didn't
know you could go so far back i mean
it's so far back
that i mean jesus christ it's so far
back that
i mean
jesus christ it's so far back to jesus
christ yeah i agree
so
then i i go oh and then i feel
a release of ants that's what i feel now
i know that's not what happened but
that's what my experience was i feel
like he released
60 ants
that's how i feel okay then he goes and
another one other nostril
i feel
like
he released 60 more ants
so now i feel
like there are 120 ants buzzing around
in my brain now
you might be like but chris
what did he say he was going to do
and i would be like
hey we're in the same boat do you know
why because we're together do you know
why because we both don't know
and the doctor's the captain
now why didn't the captain tell us what
was going on when it feels like
120 ants
are rummaging around in my brain
i think he was just trying to put you at
ease and not worry you
by
saying too much oh i should also preface
this this might be part of the reason
can't wait to say i can't wait to speak
okay but that's fine go ahead
no no go ahead okay his wife was
trying to tell you things about the
surgery and what was going to happen
proceeding
right after she was going to give the iv
she was telling him everything that was
going to happen leading up to going into
the or
and you said
this is making me nervous and she said
oh okay
i won't tell you anymore okay and he's
talking about the surgery
she stuck with the surgery
she's talking about the surgery she was
talking about everything leading up he
didn't tell me he was going to [ __ ]
blast dance in my brain okay well yeah
because
no that's not he wasn't in the room then
yes got out of that one he was in the
room yes got out of that one yes dude
but he was still doing the surgery so
she was still telling you things that
her husband was going to be doing so it
feels like 120 ants are in my brain
my my heart's going and i say hey
i'm nervous as [ __ ] right they got my
heart on the monitor i said what's
what's going on and he said oh i i said
what'd you just do he said oh i just
numbed you up there and i said already
and he said oh yeah we do it beforehand
and i say oh my god it feels so [ __ ]
weird when you're inside your face gets
numb dude it feels so [ __ ] weird when
the inside of your face gets numb i did
not like it it feels uncomfortable as
[ __ ] it felt like my brain was exploding
so i say
wanting some comfort did you did you get
my brain
and he said
always
and then internally
hold on
hold on he said always
i my blood pressure was so low dude i
said did he hit my brain he
he says always decided to toss a joke on
out and i go like this oh peace out bro
hey bro oh dude hey that's about my
limit man i'll catch you on the flip
and i [ __ ] i didn't know i did this
she said i started convulsing
i didn't know i passed out until
dude the guy goes always oh you want to
oh i know you're joking but there's a
part of me that's also a little bit
nervous because you could poke through
couldn't you you could poke through and
hit the brain but you're going to take
that and run with it oh dude real quick
let me shut the door on you peace out
[Music]
i mean
your interpretation of that is so
amazing what if i really did say peace
out to him
that would be so amazing
well you just said i don't feel very
good yes i don't feel very good
and then i was like oh here it comes and
then
you
started fading yeah it was like you were
acting out somebody having a seizure
like it just like how i did right now
yeah
[ __ ] yeah and i was outside of my body
it was like one of those moments where i
was so stressed out that
i kind of separated myself it was like i
was looking for astral projections yeah
i was just like what is my husband dying
yep i thought but guess what i was
thinking is your husband dying i knew
you weren't oh i didn't my aunts were
like we'll see what's happening yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're gonna kill
this [ __ ] yeah
i thought i was dying i started thinking
of calvin i got sad you did yeah i did
dude
oh i really did i got sad but then i
don't remember [ __ ] after that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah well you fully passed out
your blood pressure dropped there were
some beeps because like your
vitals were going wow and the doctor and
his wife were just both like it's okay
relax you're okay you're okay you could
have been saying okay could've been
trying to sell me a refrigerator i have
no idea and i was just like
in the corner
ghost
and then
maybe 10 seconds later you came to
and
i was like all right there we go and
that i do remember that because then she
was like the nurse was like all right
you're okay you're okay and she was like
and also i gave you something that's why
you're starting to feel better i said
cool good i remember i went like this
yeah because i that thank you for doing
that right she gave me a little
something well you said you started to
feel better like immediately it was like
all the stress that you had been
accumulating for those couple of days
just mounted in this weird crazy pass
out thing and then almost immediately
you were fine after it was so funny you
walked yourself to the or
i did i remember that yeah i remember
taking the thing and i remember he said
get on the gurney and he said lay down
and i laid the wrong ways like no this
way i was like oops and that's all i
remember i remember as i was going back
i remember oh and i don't remember [ __ ]
after that then i woke up and i don't
remember this why don't you take the
reigns this is why mainly why i brought
you on the show to tell this part
so in the meantime
you had gone into the or
and
the wife the anesthesiologist yes um she
came to me and she was like hey chris
doesn't have an option anymore because
he the doctor really wanted you to go to
aftercare yes to stay for a night
and she was like after that thing he's
absolutely going he doesn't have a
choice and i was like totally get that
that sounds like a good move so i went
home packed up a little um like baby
suitcase for you
came back to the hospital regular-sized
man's suitcase but yeah yeah right
around the time that you were getting
out it was like two hours
your surgery was an hour and fifteen is
what he's told me but oh maybe i i mean
who knows the whole day is a blur but i
walked in and i knew everything was fine
because there was music on in the
office and they were all eating
and like asking each other what they
were eating so it's like everything went
fine obviously doctor comes in
and he was like surgery was beautiful 11
out of 10 went totally great i was like
oh thank god
and then he said um i'm going to wait
for him to wake up
and then you can go back there because i
have a feeling that he's going to wake
up real crazy
[Laughter]
and i said what do you mean and he was
like well he's just never done drugs in
his life and like he doesn't really know
what it feels like
to be under this much anesthesia and
right as he was telling me this i heard
like that in the back room and he was
like oh god he's waking up he's going to
be
he jumped crazy into the room and i
went into the part that i wasn't
supposed to be in this like little hot
yeah oh [ __ ] this little hallway
and it sounded like
it sounded like a woolly mammoth was
getting into a fight
it was like
and they were all yelling five doctors
and nurses yelling chris no chris lay
down chris you're out of surgery don't
hate your nose chris and you were trying
to take out the ivs and fight all the
doctors and nurses to get out and i was
like oh my god
i mean if like if i had to guess what
you would have been like
write all the money
just
[Music]
yeah
justin wild it wild and oh wild animal
don't you know what that goes to show
you dude it takes five [ __ ] people to
take me down
it takes five people to take me down
surgery man
dude
that's cool that i did that okay
i
apologize the next day yeah
you apologized the day of actually yeah
but i wanted to do it with my wits about
me not under anesthesiology
so i went back and i was like dude i'm
really sorry he's like dude there's
nothing you do about it like you know
it's not you and i was like i'm just
really sorry and then he was like i i
had anesthesia and i woke up and i was
doing weird [ __ ] too and i was like yeah
but you didn't try to [ __ ] like
kill everybody i like literally was like
i don't know what i don't remember it at
all but i was like trying to fight them
physically dude it was the primal noises
like on both ends because i have
i don't think i've ever heard you
like that i've heard you cry i keep the
beast inside yeah i've heard you cry in
like a really primal way but i've never
heard that's actually let's
that's hilarious
good joke yeah no i cry but i don't cry
primal i let it out i go
ha and then i'm all good dude yes that's
it yeah she's acting like i'm here
[ __ ]
hilarious
glad okay
um
but you were very primal and your noise
like the
just you not knowing where you were and
you trying to get up and get off
of the table and then the nurses and the
doctors that were like oh [ __ ] he could
take us down
[Music]
yeah
it was wild just like screaming and
noises and moaning and a wild wild scene
there you go
yeah
well that was the surgery chronicles and
uh
now my nose is all stuffed up i blew my
nose lightly not supposed to do it but i
did it a little bit well and then you
went to aftercare and then you broke out
yeah i didn't want to be there he didn't
want to be there so we broke him out
he said that the doctor gave him the
okay to go home
and he did not
and i
[Music]
yeah just a menace from start to finish
when they said well you shouldn't leave
you should get the okay from your doctor
and i say oh okay i was gonna stay the
night and they said i mean we
technically can't keep you against your
will and i go oh really
[Music]
me out with the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
they actually didn't say that we can't
keep you against your will you just said
well they can't tell me what to do they
did say that they did they did say that
no
you got class
huh you got class babe i know i love you
i love you
and you made it out yeah and you look
great and you know what i was very
surprised by and i'll tell your
listeners this [ __ ] i don't know how
this is which way
i was so anticipating the last five days
to be
like i was a nurse
i was like he's going to be insufferable
to be around
and asking me for stuff crying in so
much pain
it's going to be a wild experience and
you have been lovely really lovely
you've been a little moody
[Music]
you can't take me that one knows
run up uh sign up what they call it
yeah you've been great thanks only
complaining a moderate that's all the
time we have oh
okay cool
all right well yeah so that's that
thanks for telling the story
that's it or what i love you oh okay
well i love you too
but this isn't about that this was a
documentary oh it was yeah okay this is
the document that stuff it's good we'll
have that kevin i'll see that later i
got a headache for my sinuses [ __ ] yeah
dude got a headache from a sinuses i
didn't take coding today though
my man my [ __ ] man that's not
something to say to that i didn't take
cody
name my [ __ ] man um all right
so yeah that's good now i can do the
regular episode thanks for telling my
listeners that was for like 40 minutes
they're going to love that wow yeah it's
a long time yeah i know it flies by it
does well when there's two people when
there's one sometimes that it moves as a
snail space all right okay cool love you
uh see you in a little bit on the flip
catch you on the flip have fun at class
thank you babe uh
take your time getting out okay take
your time getting out
take some getting out
take time getting out take a big big
challenge take your chalice
see ya
hell yeah dude
[Music]
dude
so that's what we do
so now i have a different nose dude and
it's different now and it's all good but
it's it's fine should i move this should
we cut and should i move this [ __ ]
or what
it doesn't really matter
nothing really matters to me
hey guys we're back dude i had to pee
and
uh all that dude it's good man we're
good that was fun i can't believe i
don't remember that [ __ ] it is crazy
that that that that
that's what i don't like i never like
being on drugs or like under any sort of
influence like ever since i used to
watch those old batman tv shows with
adam west when they would re-show them
in the 80s um
that like when when uh the penguin and
like
joker made people like laugh or pass out
or like
laugh and gas that should freak me out
man i think it's all from that for real
uh which is insane that that could
really affect someone just from
childhood like that but yeah man uh i
don't like that even with the like the
pain pills i took the pain pills because
like
i'm slowly kind of like
being better about not being so
hard-lined you know
uh so i took coding
uh for the nose it really hurt man it
really [ __ ] hurts i don't know i saw
so many like
um
uh youtube videos like i watched them do
the uh surgeries on youtube and do the
it is absolutely insane and everyone has
different [ __ ] opinions on it like
some people are like yeah like there's
one guy who did a surgery came out after
surgery and he was like they didn't put
packing in my nose and he went home and
he was chilling no blood his nose didn't
look swollen i'm like this is just a
little is he just lying did he not get
surgery and he was like day two i'm
pretty chill been [ __ ] all day like
dude it's crazy
they say not supposed to [ __ ] for two
weeks afterwards
uh
so um
yeah and then some people are like it
took a total of six months for me to
breathe again and i'm like oh for [ __ ]
sake nobody told me that
so apparently my nose could be swollen
for six months
but uh yeah man they cut into the middle
part
the the septum and they it's it's curved
like mine is curved so because i can't
breathe out of the right nostril i can
breathe here i can't breathe here
because this blocks it right such a good
diagram and uh
he takes this out takes out the septum
and then cuts it up
and then puts it together straight and
then puts it back in the nose
and it's apparently
they say it's a minor surgery but it
hurts so much because it's in your
[ __ ] head in your face so the pain is
all right here
and it's just like come on
dude
this is like yeah okay but it's going to
hurt this one so come on
like i can't even do a high note like
oh when i go do n or m or p
dude my [ __ ] hurts so bad and my
sunglasses fell on it like on the top
part and i go like this oh i'm going to
pull over i'll pull over i just sat
there
okay oh it's going to hurt this much
i was going this much just gonna hurt
this small almost like this one up on my
head oh these are lightweight oh these
are paperweight i was gonna do this much
okay
hurts so much dude
um
so anyway uh it's gonna be good i slowly
blew my nose i'm not supposed to you're
not supposed to blow your nose for like
a [ __ ] three weeks or some [ __ ] i
slowly blew it i took tweezers and also
q-tips got the gunk out it's gross but
so worth it cause now i can breathe and
i still got the stents in there when it
takes the stencil dude i'm gonna breathe
like i got i'm gonna breathe like i got
a hole just a [ __ ] straight up hole
in the middle of my face i can't wait uh
so yeah
uh but yeah i took that coating
i took it for
five four days i didn't take it today uh
i took it for four days and i think that
that felt man i felt weird after
anesthesia for like four days
uh but then felt uh now today i kind of
feel normal i did lifeline
uh yesterday was it yesterday was that
yesterday saturday two days ago i felt
really weird doing lifeline i was doing
life on the middle life and i felt like
i was gonna pass out but that episode is
up you could go to super cult studios
subscribe to the channel super cult
um
and uh yeah and uh and i did that
episode and i almost passed out in the
middle of it because of uh just being so
out of it man it really [ __ ] you up
it's bad for you right
uh anesthesia but i don't know
uh
that guy uh tony cirico died right uh
from uh goodfellas was it or
was that every mob movie probably he's
in but he died and i uh uh that that's
paulie walnut oh that's from sopranos
right
dude i thought he already died this is i
swear to god this is one of those uh
what do they call them the the the
mandela effects dude i swear to god it's
a mandela effect who's with me he
already died
he died now again
i thought he was already it was like
that move the kazam shazam everyone
thinks that [ __ ] it's shazam with
sinbad somebody with shaq though
and it's a genie and they call it shazam
uh or uh what's another one of the
mandela effect
that uh
do you know what the mandela effect is
fruit
about what
mandela effect
okay look mandela effect false memories
can sometimes be shared by multiple
people that is crazy this phenomenon was
dubbed the mandela effect by paranormal
researcher fiona broome that's where you
get lost the paranormal researcher uh
fiona broome who reported having vivid
and detailed memories of news coverage
of south africa anti-apartheid leader
nelson mandela dying in prison there you
go
shimaharan tony
him two equally great mans
uh
nelson mandela and the guy from the
sopranos
uh
what are good examples of the mandela
effect
yeah yeah yeah a common example of the
mandela effect relates to curious george
the children's book character that first
appeared in 1940's the book
and his lack of a tale remember curious
george is having a good tale just
that's a stupid one it's just like you
just don't think of it that much and
then you go does it retail or not you
don't know don't do it okay
the berenstain bears is a big one
uh
huh
i bet i guess everybody just this is
just i don't like this whole mandela
effect really of what it is is just like
a bunch of people are wrong about
something
that's what it is it's not there's no
effect you're just a [ __ ] idiot you
know like i thought this guy tony cyriko
died i'm wrong whoops no mandela effect
just not [ __ ] informed that's what
char
um
but yeah that was weird when i heard he
died i'm like again
uh i wonder is anybody else with me
leave leave in the comments so i can
ignore it uh
but uh
this just just you know it's got to stop
honestly the hot dog eating competitions
stop
it's so disgusting always
they look so gross and they're so
red-faced
and they're you know what they're doing
when they're doing it dying they look
like they're dying and then somebody
tried to protest out there they tried to
hold the sign out and protest something
that nobody even read and then that
[ __ ] joey chestnut dude just choked
them out
like
how hilarious that you you didn't even
compete
in the competition of hot dog eating and
you're the one that choked
you were just holding the sign and joey
chestnut by the way
worst name dude is he in a boy band do
joey chestnut is that hey joey chestnut
p.i need any certainty my services i'll
get to the bottom of it joey chestnut
that's not his real name right it can't
be
if it's not his real name why didn't he
just name himself joey hot dog
yeah i'm gonna eat so many hot dogs be
the ultimate winner and then also my
last name is [ __ ] a different food is
that even a food chestnut it's roasting
on an open fire
eating so many hot dogs at once
eat like 60 hot dogs my only competition
is kibiashi
oh joey
what's the guy's name kobayashi
my only competition is
that guy kobayashi or song of all time
joey chestnuts choking
out protesters
never choking myself
i eat hot dogs so clean it's like i'm
sucking the dicks
i'm basically sucking dicks
this is low-key homosexual
it's actually
high-key homosexual
because i'm eating
phallic things in the shape of dicks
also i changed my lame to
two words that technically are
homosexual if you think about it because
the only thing that's more homosexual
than the word nut is
chest
couple them together chestnuts the
gayest thing ever
[Laughter]
i'm so dizzy for my nose surgery yeah
yes dude
he can't hold a note without passing out
but he does it for you because he
is a ceo
dude
oh my nose [ __ ] hurts
how many black dudes outside of
buildings that don't go in the buildings
hand people cards and say that they're
ceos of something yes doing your nails
oh
holy [ __ ] dude
that's blacker than the cheeky for real
dude
oh [ __ ] oh i'm so dizzy dude
oh my god dude
so many [ __ ] black dudes stand
outside of buildings and don't go into
buildings and hand people cards that
come out of the buildings and say you
know i'm a ceo
dude
it's unreal dude
joey chestnuts roasting on an open fire
it's so gay i put things the size of
dicks in my face over and over again
the only word gayer than nut is chest
put them together that's the gay singing
of the world
nut on my chest
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] man
oh [ __ ]
i wish these hot dogs squirted come out
of them
anyway dude
is that like a picture of joey chestnut
he's looking is it so gross
[Laughter]
did they drink water
in the middle of that oh god that's so
gross bro
he looks so british too he looks like
he'd be in [ __ ] what's it called uh
that was that movie with train spotting
oh you got dogs we gotta go in we got a
dro that's a [ __ ] new that's how how
much does [ __ ] joy chestnut look like
you being a guy richie movie where
they're trying to rob a bunch of hot
dogs
we're gonna go in we gotta get all the
dogs we gotta go in we gotta get all the
beef franks
collect them all in these [ __ ] buns
eat them before we leave there's a
number of hot dogs and we're gonna run
out
uh anyway he's a champ dude
so
disrespectful to july 4th to have that
[ __ ] competition on july 4th dude so
disrespectful so american but so
disrespectful nothing is more american
than having a hot dog eating competition
uh
to take over the independence day
holiday
the only more
american than that is being that
disrespectful and they did it so that's
great
so i laughed too hard i sang too hard
and i hurt and i hurt my nose and it's
all good and i feel faint but it's all
good definitely can't do stand up yet i
want to do stand up the doctor said
three weeks
i go like this
okay and then it's time like these i
think well that's why i'm not the doctor
paint's crazy huh really takes a toll on
you it's deeper um hey guys that was the
end of the episode for youtube if you
want to catch the rest of the episode
the raw and the uncut version uh the
extended episode with no breaks go on
over to patreon.comcrystalia
and uh you can listen to every episode
uncut and how it was intended to be
listened to and then also you can
uh get one episode a month extra and
there's also other things like we do
review mode we do different segments we
do different shows and uh we got a
a discord that we chat on sometimes and
uh so that's over at patreon.com that's
for only six bucks a month so go on and
sign up thanks guys for listening
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you